- All right.
You know it, and I know it,
sometimes this world can
be a little upside down
and that's why I love
that here on this show
we can be a vessel to
share fun and positivity.
So from time to time we
look back at all our shows
to bring you mash up moments we love.
So today it's all about the crazy jobs
our celebrity guests have
had before they were stars.
Check it out.
What was your first real job?
- I worked in a fish and chip shop.
I was the potato peeler.
- Were you a runner in a recording studio?
- Amongst other things, yeah.
- I'm a fourth generation dog shower.
Yeah. There's me at some of the dog shows.
- I worked at the Bronx zoo for a summer.
- I worked at the Fort Worth zoo.
- Really?
- Yes, for a summer.
- Oh my goodness.
- I used to work at the Four
Seasons hotel in Beverly Hills.
I waited on anywhere from Nicole Kidman,
to Al Pacino, to Robert De Niro.
So yeah.
- I bet you all of them were
waiters at some point too.
I feel like we all were waitress.
Were you a good waiter?
- I was not only a waiter,
I was selling satellite dishes...
- (Kelly laughs)
- Out of a kiosk in the ghetto. So, uh.
- I sold vacuum cleaners for two days.
- Is that right?
- Uh-huh, and I was like, I'm out.
Mm-hm, yeah, I couldn't do it.
- We all had these jobs. - Yeah.
- I used to glaze ham at Honey Baked Ham.
- Oh my gosh, those are good!
- Honey Baked Ham! Look.
- Those are good.
We get those for like
Christmas and Thanksgiving.
I'm not kidding, they're so good.
- Yeah, I glazed them.
- Nicely done. - Yeah.
- You are great at glazing. - Thank you.
- See? It's all this that
builds to where you are now.
- And when I was like, yeah,
I'm gonna tweet Marvel,
and it's gonna be great.
They're gonna, you know, read the tweet
get back to me, offer me a role.
- Mm-hm.
- I also just kind of
picked up like, you know,
weird modeling gigs whenever I could.
And like, oh, when I say modeling
I'm not I'm, I wasn't
like a runway Prada model.
I was like, I was like a
stock, you know, stock photos.
- Wait, like when you
buy the picture frame?
- Like when you, when you buy
the picture frame exactly.
Or like when you go on a website.
- I always think those
families are so beautiful.
I'm like sometimes yeah,
I, yeah,
I'm like, well done if
they cast you for that.
- Yeah. The one I did like a
couple of shoots and they ended
up like, I literally
keep seeing it pop up,
and like more so now 'cause
people are recognizing them.
- So tell us about your motivation
in some of these photos.
What's happening here?
- Oh man.
- It's the merger? You're
discussing the merger?
- There's the merger.
There's a merger, Kelly.
Thank you. Thank you.
There's a lot going on in this, guys.
A lot of really, really
intense character work.
- Yeah.
- You know, I see my
two colleagues over here
they're studying an annual report, right?
And I, over there leaning over
the the head of the table.
- Yeah.
And, and leading this meeting, all right?
- Yes. A leader.
You look like a leader.
- Thank you. - Yeah.
- Thank you. I appreciate that.
- If that was what the
motivation was, you nailed it.
How about this one?
This is our next one.
- I think I've been promoted
since the last photo.
- I feel like you're gonna
sell me the best house
in the entire land.
You did have an interesting job
that we actually have in common.
You were a telemarketer?
- Oh, you were a telemarketer too?
- I was.
- Oh dang!
- I was a telemarketer for the comedy club
I cocktail-waitressed for.
- Oh, you did that.
- So I got to kind of
sell them free tickets,
but there's a two drink minimum.
- I did a lot of weird.
I like sold Time Life
books over the phone.
I sold steaks.
- Steaks? Omaha Steaks.
- Omaha Steaks is where I worked.
Yeah. - Yeah.
- It would be a lot of me...
- Is that like, how do you sell that?
Mine was easier.
- I would call, and my
main thing, it' so stupid,
I would take a piece of paper,
and this was like my closer.
I would wiggle the piece of
paper in front of my face
which is where the headset was.
And then I go, sorry, excuse
me, my manager's here.
What's that?
No, I can't. Really?
No!
What?
And then I get back and
I'm like, I'm so sorry.
I can't believe this is happening
but this just came in from upstairs.
One floor building. This
came in from upstairs.
We're gonna cut the price
of those filets by half.
- (Kelly laughs)
- I can't believe we're doing this!
And then people like.
Everyone wants a deal.
- Oh my God!
- And then you just say,
now does that VISA start with a four?
They all do.
Yes. And what are those other numbers?
A one?
- Oh my God, you are a liar!
- Yeah.
- You're good at it!
- Got 'em! Ha-ha! And that
paid for my 1993 Cavalier.
- Yeah.